let's go to our next caller from the 706
area code caller what's your name where
are you calling from and and what's on
your mind today hi my name is Samuel I'm
in Georgia and I started listening to
progressive media through secular talk
actually and I found your channel on
YouTube great and my question was if you
are I wanted to know if you are
considering collaborating more with Kyle
kolinsky like you did recently with the
YouTube apocalypse yeah video I'm always
open to collaborating with Kyle you know
everybody sort of has their own schedule
on a day to day basis and oftentimes it
seems like it should just be super easy
to regularly make it a point to do a
collaboration or crossover video but
it's often tougher than it seems
everybody has you know a pretty full
production day as you know Pat so I'm
totally open to it I just don't know the
logistics of it even just doing what we
did with Kyle over the You Tube
advertiser boycott I guess now it's been
about close to a month ago at this point
it's not always that easy to put it
together you know what I mean did you
also talk to Kyle about some report that
alleged most YouTube content is
right-wing and that was completely bogus
right that the successful YouTube
political content is right-wing content
or something like that anyway so I'm
guessing that you you're into the idea
of crossovers with Kyle yes of course
all right well very get any other
crossovers that I should consider doing
that's the only one on my mind I
wouldn't be against you cross them over
with any other progressive media I think
that Bendixon should make a return to
the show while you're here
that's an involving all three of us in
studio that's an interesting idea that
would definitely be something to look
into
alright very good thank you so much for
the call really appreciate it and we can
certainly look into that Pat and see
what what what may come of it